Hallo meine Lieben!
Ich möchte die Erdbeersaison ja so richtig ausnutzen,
deswegen gab's jetzt auch schon ein paar Erdbeer-Rezepte.
Und heute gibt's auch eins und zwar ein schnelles No Bake Erdbeer-Dessert.
Und dafür fange ich jetzt auch direkt an, gar nicht lange drumherum quatschen!
Hier habe ich meine kalte Schlagsahne, alle ganz genauen Mengenangaben findet ihr
wie immer unten in der Videobeschreibung. Hier habe ich meine kalte Schlagsahne,
es ist natürlich immer gut wenn die Schlagsahne kalt ganz frisch aus dem Kühlschrank kommt.
Nicht 10min stehen lassen und dann erst schlagen!
Und was ich auch immer mache, das sage ich euch immer gerne öfter auch als Tipp:
ich gebe die Schüssel in den Kühlschrank für 10min und den Schneebesen-Aufsatz.
Und dann kann euch nichts mehr schief gehen beim Aufschlagen von Sahne!
So, ich lass das jetzt steif schlagen 1min lang, lass dann Sahnefest einrieseln
und dann ungefähr noch 1/2min und dann ist es richtig schön steif!
So, unsere Sahne ist jetzt steif, die kommt ganz kurz an die Seite und weiter geht's mit den nächsten Zutaten!
Ich hab jetzt hier Mascarpone weil ich finde die gibt nochmal so ein richtig schönes Mundgefühl
und ist sehr sehr cremig, deswegen gebe ich jetzt Mascarpone in meine Schüssel.
Und um das Ganze so ein bisschen aufzulockern und damit's auch nicht so schwer im Magen liegt,
möchte ich das mit ein bisschen Quark verrühren. Und ich finde Quark, Mascarpone -
(H: *krächzend* QUARK!)
und Sahne...hallo?!
(H: Ich hab dir nachgesprochen! Quaark!)
Quark, Mascarpone und Sahne, das ist für mich ein schönes Trio, ja!
(H: *krächzend* Quaark!)
So da geben wir noch Puderzucker für die Süße dazu und Vanilleextrakt für den Geschmack
und anschließend ca 30sek lang mit dem Schneebesen verrühren damit's schön cremig wird.
Und dann heben wir die Sahne unter und da nehmt ihr euch am besten einen Teigschaber.
So, fertig ist die Creme! Wie lange haben wir jetzt gebraucht für alles Hamza?
(H: ...4 Stunden?)
(H: Ja ok, Viertelstunde!)
Drei Minuten!
(H: Was?!)
(H: Ja ich weiß nicht, ich hab alles aufgenommen hier!)
Ok ja, Hamza filmt und so und dieses "Ja, rück mal die Schüssel nach links!" und so,
das dürfen wir ja nicht mitzählen!
(H: Okay, alles klar!)
Ihr zuhause habt bis zu diesem Schritt drei Minuten gebraucht!
(H: Achsoo, jetzt verstehe ich was du meinst, ja!)
So und jetzt geht's weiter.
Jetzt wird einfach nur noch geschichtet Leute, das ist so easy!
Ich hab jetzt meinen Backrahmen hier eingestellt auf 25x25cm.
Und jetzt habe ich hier - ich glaub die nennt man...
Biskuitzungen?
Auf jeden Fall -
(H: Katzenzungen!)
Nee, Katzenzungen sind wieder anders! Die mag ich aber auch gerne! Biskuitzungen!
Ihr könnten auch Löffelbiskuits oder eure Lieblingskekse nehmen.
Wichtig ist, dass ihr sie jetzt in Milch tunkt damit sie - ja, halt ein bisschen weich werden,
Die werden zwar auch durch die Creme nach der Kühlzeit weich,
aber sie brauchen doch - also wirklich nur eine Sekunde! So eins, rausnehmen abtropfen lassen
und dann hier auf den Boden geben.
Und dann werde ich gleich einfach nur die Hälfte der Creme drauf verstreichen!
So, jetzt habe ich die erste Hälfte der Creme glatt verstrichen
und jetzt machen wir eigentlich wieder das Gleiche.
Das heißt wieder die - wie hießen die jetzt nochmal? - die Zungenbiskuits
in Milch tunken, eine ganze Schicht voll machen und dann die restliche Creme da darüber geben.
So und ihr könnt jetzt bei meiner Spezial Palette 2.0 nicht nur hier vorne die Spitze
zum verstreichen benutzen.
Das heißt ihr könnt nicht nur hier in die Ecken ran sondern ihr nehmt auch jetzt hier den 90° Winkel
und könnt dann mit der Seite ebenfalls verstreichen.
So, als nächstes schneiden wir frische Erdbeeren. Also ich viertel sie,
ihr könnt sie aber auch nur einmal halbieren, ganz wie ihr möchtet.
Und geb das jetzt auf die Oberfläche und gleich kommt noch ein Tortenguss,
den zeige ich euch aber gleich am Herd.
So, die Erdbeeren sind drauf und das sieht jetzt so auch schon richtig schick aus!
Aber ich mache auf jeden Fall einen Tortenguss drauf weil erstens schmeckt der mir einfach
und zweitens ist die Torte somit ein bisschen länger haltbar.
Weil wenn ihr die Erdbeeren anschneidet, dann sind sie ganz schnell nicht mehr haltbar,
dann muss man das sofort essen! Und so bleibt die Torte kühl gelagert 3 Tage lang haltbar.
Das heißt im Umkehrschluss: ihr könnt sie auch einen Tag z.B. vorher vorbereiten,
da kommt die Frage nämlich auch immer ganz oft. So, für den Tortenguss benötigen wir Sauerkirschsaft.
Einfach deswegen weil der rot ist und ich möcht gern einen roten Tortenguss.
Und da gebe ich jetzt eine Packung Agartine rein, das entspricht 10 gramm.
Einmal reinrühren klümpchenfrei und dann den Herd einschalten und das Ganze 2min lang
sprudelnd kochen und dann fängt es nämlich nach dem Kühlen an zu gelieren.
Man aktiviert es quasi durch dieses 2min lang sprudelnd kochen lassen.
Nach den 2min habe ich das Ganze auch nochmal 10min stehen lassen
damit ich das jetzt nicht ganz so heiß auf meine Erdbeeren gebe.
Genau, ansonsten müsst ihr nichts beachten. Ich nehm mir jetzt einfach einen Löffel
und geb das vorsichtig drüber
und anschließend kommt das zum Kühlen in den Kühlschrank.
So und jetzt ab in den Kühlschrank damit für mindestens eine Stunde.
Besser sind zwei, dann kann noch mal alles schön fest werden, alles zieht schön in die Zungenbiskuits ein,
die Tortenglasur wird fest und alles wird einfach optimal zum vernaschen!
Und ich denke, dass euch dieses Rezept auch sehr gut gefällt
weil es praktisch ist, anfängerfreundlich, wenige Zutaten und rucki zucki!
Nach dem Backen dann einfach den Backformlöser nehmen und den Backrahmen entfernen
und dann könnt ihr euch das in beliebig große Stücke einteilen.
Ich wünsche euch ganz viel Freude beim Nachmachen!
Hinterlasst diesem Video ein...?
(H: Däumchen nach oben!)
Ein Däumchen nach oben und ein kostenloses Abo! Guter Einsatz immer hinter der Kamera, gefällt mir!
(H: Heute bin ich konzentriert!)
Ja, mega konzentriert sogar!
So, euch jetzt ganz viel Freude beim Nachmachen
und beim nächsten Mal sehen wir uns dann wieder hier auf KikisKitchen!
Tschüss!
(H: *mit hoher Stimme* Eure Kiki!)
Eure Kiki!